so we thought we'd start with them two
images actually so start at the
beginning
buzz flew twice into space on Gemini 12
and of course in Apollo 11 and there's a
particular image that's not news to you
I heard so if we could see the first
image this is famous for many reasons
but we're talking about it earlier it's
also we think the first ever selfie in
space so Buzz could you describe this
spectacular image from Gemini 12 well
the mission was ultraviolet photographs
of star clusters at night so Jim Lovell
the commander would locate the
spacecraft at the right position and
then turn off the thrusters so they
wouldn't fire while I with the hatch
open stood on the seat and operated this
camera in time exposures 5 seconds 10
seconds whatever it was and the
spacecraft might be drifting a little
but it would catch this an ultraviolet
now between two different night passes
there was about 50 minutes of daylight
coming back for the next so we we were
real sightseers at least I was because I
was standing in the open hatch and
looking down at the parts of Texas and
in other parts and I was reminded as
cameras blind me I jail wonder if it
could take a picture of me
and turned out pretty good I didn't
check the lighting too well we have to
either move the Sun or we have to move a
little in orbit to another location but
so to get these builded geometries
you're in the Gemini spacecraft I
suppose it's smaller than this actually
and Jim Lovell had to sit in his seat
with his space suit on and you got to
stand did he not say to you I would like
to see us were sort of like this because
they were ejection seats and if you
eject and you go and slightly different
but you do that on the launch pad if you
had to yeah so you could eject from
Jamie 9 mm-hmm after this there wasn't
an escape tower the way mercury had and
the way Apollo did also now you
pioneered the the early spacewalk
technology didn't you because we are
interesting diving that you said to me
that you'd wanted to when it it's a
little bit the other way around we were
experiencing difficulties some missions
had to be stopped
terminated early and we didn't get to do
that space walking or there was a
situation where the person doing the
spacewalk was getting overheated and
then he got frustrated and trying to do
something so there there was not really
a great success Mike Collins on Gemini
10 and a maneuvering guard Leo the
Hatcher moved out and and did everything
with her actually it was a dead a Gina
it was left up there from the previous
mission but when he caught back in he
had to mess around with the umbilical so
we always had some things going wrong
and I had been training to do this
backpack maneuvering unit on on the last
flight Germany 12 because it hadn't been
flown on the flight nine before I was
under backup crew on that one so this is
the last chance to use this number one
air force experiment and someone has
suggested from around Baltimore they did
some research and discovered that if you
were neutrally buoyant under water that
it behaved quite a bit like being in
space where you would be floating so
they had suggested and and being a scuba
diver from nine years previous I I felt
yeah this this I think we'll really want
some of the other astronauts and now you
don't think that's good but they were
wrong and I was right and it did make
things easier but still NASA was a
little conservative so they canceled the
backpack maneuvering unit and I was
really disappointed because I would have
loved to have separated and and fly
around the spacecraft NASA insisted on
him underfoot tether all that would do
is get in your way but those of you
who've seen the movie gravity George
Clooney was flying around with a
backpack that's what I was going to do
but but it was cancelled on that flights
and on Gemini 12 yes so I just did some
very simple tasks but it there were
three different successful evie a is
short the long one taking a selfie
and then another one were I was going to
activate the backpack and then there was
a young garbage disposal da we had some
things that we needed to get rid of so
we opened up the hatch and you would
appreciate this we were fine like this
and I had these nice robot straight up
not thinking that oh they're going to go
up come back yeah and one orbit laser
there sure enough there they were yeah
they just passed buying it yeah cuz I
think I remember talking to Chris
Hadfield recently about when they throw
things off the space station you're
supposed to throw them down and forwards
aren't you to get them out of the way I
think yes I said what you said if you
throw them up you just meet them again
yeah so you said there that you meant oh
if you throw them down they're gonna
call like to go back I should sell it
see because your PhD was on this wasn't
it at MIT it was on docking maneuvers in
orbit or orbital dynamics and I remember
I read that you talked about a
conservative nature of NASA but so you
became an astronaut in 63 on them and
then on the back of that PhD from MIT
and then three years later you're in
space so the pace of it seems to be
anything but conservative in that sense
well yes when when the training for
Gemini was gone
some of the early missions and I helped
to train some of the people along with
the company McDonnell Douglas for the
first rendezvous and I had asked the top
guy I said you know I'd like to fly on
one of these rendezvous flights fiance
anything
but then as the assignments came out I
was going to back up a flight and then
switch to prime crew but there wasn't
any mission so I wasn't going to fly on
Germany but then a tragedy took the life
of my back door neighbor and then we
moved to replace him on Gemini 9 and has
a crew for 10 and 11 so then Jim Lovell
and I to unjam II 12 and I was a success
so then I was in good position to be
selected to fly an Apollo mission so
Neil and I were assigned to what
eventually became Apollo 8 the first
flight to orbit the moon and I was
really a wonderful flight to be on the
backup group and then to see all the
training in Neil and I worked pretty
close together on that and then the
normal rotation would be after Apollo 8
was a crew to Apollo 9 and 10 so we
would fly on Apollo 11 and if everything
worked out we might be able to make the
first attempted landing all worked out
pretty good
speaking of that we have a second
picture that we wanted to talk about
which is which is this one from Apollo
11 and I should ask who is that a
photograph of it I suppose it's a fairly
obvious answer that would be both given
the conversation we have it but manica
is probably the most famous picture from
the surface of the Moon I would say and
many people say that's a Neil Armstrong
but in fact it's you and Neil in the
reflection so what was the story of that
there's probably most iconic
photographic human history actually all
Neil was such a excellent
see I I was walking along like this and
he said hey stop try stop looked at him
and he took the picture right away and
you can see parts well you can identify
that that I was just still moving a
little bit but people ask me because
it's so so well staged and we call it
the visor picture because the reflection
in the visor will show the landing craft
and it'll show the white suited
astronaut Neil that took the picture and
you can see my shadow moving out so we
call that the the visor picture but
people have asked me why is that such a
perfect an iconic picture and I've got
three words location I should actually
be about that you must have been asked
all the time over the last decades but
what to land on the moon and to walk out
you've spoken about it many times but it
might be worth saying a few words about
what that feels like to come down the
ladder and onto the surface of the Moon
well we certainly knew that the pressure
was going to be on us to be able to to
do that of course due to all of us the
most important thing and that mission
was to make a landing if you don't make
a landing you can't go outside you have
to do it again and then but that's not
the way the the press and the media see
what's the most important thing is
opening
Lichter well i was easy but there was
some controversy because it was the
first time that two people were going to
go out previously on all previous
spacewalks the commander was so occupied
training for the very complex things he
had to do and make decisions so
generally the experiments were given to
the pilot NASA doesn't like the word
co-pilot but the pilot always did the
space walking and as I did on timoney 12
I was the pilot Jim Lovell was the
commander but it for a number of reasons
it was decided I think the customary
thing would be that the commander does
the leading of his troops and he should
be the one symbolically to go down and
an out was the way it was decided the
experiment shal still should have been
overseen by the the junior Brisby that
isn't quite the way it worked out
because kneels down there first and then
he began I began following a brown and
that's that worked out fine
and did you it was there any suggestion
then that the you stay in there because
it just seemed to make sense doesn't it
that somebody's there you don't know
what's going to happen is the first time
on the moon it's quite bold actually to
send both astronauts out was there any
discussion about that what did they -
you know they're going out it really
wasn't do if you put a person out there
and and he were to have some trouble
best thing is to have somebody right
behind him not somebody back
and the spacecraft now if the spacecraft
is flying and the person outside then
you might have to move this base craft
over to pick him up
or you might have to be the boss be the
person then charged and and your junior
person is out there doing something yeah
and I think we touched on it before but
the rate of technological developments
and that that moved from Kennedy's
speech in less than a decade to the moon
and what did you think when you heard
Kennedy's speech first of all that you
would have a chance of being in the
space program and secondly there indeed
by the end of the decade there would be
the mission to the moon well when he
gave that speech in May of 1961 I was
still at MIT and I was kind of working
on my rendezvous thesis dealing mostly
with rendezvous around the earth but I'd
pretty well finished that and then it
looked like there was a debate sort of
between a Wernher von Braun and the
science advisor who both thought what
started with the lander that Ron Brown
and his people had designed it was big
and it would have required a much bigger
rocket the Nova rocket with nine engines
but that wouldn't be ready until into
the 70s so I wouldn't work so they had
to use two Saturn five the first would
put up the rocket stage that would take
the spacecraft to the moon so then you
send up the spacecraft and you join
together in Earth orbit and go to the
moon and the big spacecraft would then
do pretty much everything
but an engineer from another center came
along and said now if if you look at the
task of taking somebody from the earth
and putting them on the moon and you
break that up into pieces you need to
send a command module to the moon with
the crew and it needs a service module
but when you get to the moon you need to
have a lander and an asset stage so if
you put those together then you land
when you come up with the ascent stage
you have to join up with the other ship
to come back home so we leave one person
Airport two people down on the surface
and that was judged to be very risky but
it was by far the easier way to do that
and it only required one big rocket
whereas the other system required two
but that wasn't the argument was how
risky this is versus how safe this
because they want to sell more Rakas
maybe but that to me was too many of
this was the most decisive deciding how
to get there that really made the
mission successful so you think it was
obviously the right choice in the sense
that it worked but in terms of
developing a system that could go on
words out to Mars and beyond but it
wouldn't have been better to go for
those bigger rockets and that more
flexible and complicated system well it
might have let Lee enough land first and
we want that dammit
sabot was the right choice because it
seems obvious now everyone who grows up
with Apollo there's the lamb and as a
command module in the surgeon and it
just seems like the way to do it but it
is worth reflecting that back in 61
nobody knew how to do that at all it's a
blank sheet of paper and after we did it
the way there to work I'm sure that
those do people still felt that we
should have done it their way yeah but
they were wrong it would cost more and
they said well if we join things up in
Earth orbit maybe that'll lead to a
space station now that was much much
later that that would come along now I
have a strategy that makes lunar
activities much much better than that
but I can't tell you them I was just
about to ask because they you'll say
nothing about it what do you did you
think on in in 69 and we there was many
more Apollo missions planned did you
think that we'd go straight to a moon
base essentially in a single program
with Saturn 5 launching that technology
was that what you felt would happen well
when the three of us came back from a 45
day trip around the world stopping it to
replace those kings and queens and prime
ministers we came back and had dinner in
the White House and the president say
well we guys want to do now he said I
might I know you've been talking to
secretary Rogers about a State
Department and Neil said well I want to
work on arrow Aeronautics airplane
flying and work that NASA would be doing
and I said well I want to really return
back to the service that I was in the
Air Force and I became the first
astronaut that did go back now quite a
few of them too
and has been rewarding some not not in
my case but now we we could have stayed
in the crew rotation but I think about
then they were beginning to look at
maybe not flying the last tour there
were 20 missions abled but 18 19 and 20
were cancelled out and you went back
just you mention you accept that
Michener's book well but he became
apollo-soyuz didn't be one of them I
think there's one of the news for that
17 well after the last mission people
had been looking at what can we do with
this Apollo equipment and it looked like
the upper stage of the rocket there in a
first second and third stage that went
into orbit with the rest of us but if
you didn't have the rest of us there it
could go into orbit itself and become a
container for people to then visit and
there are two ways of doing that
one was to have fuel in it but burn the
fuel out and you could do that with
Saturn one but if you wanted it empty
when you lost it then you'd have to use
much bigger Saturn five and it was
decided to do the latter probably a good
idea because to go up to a station get
inside and it had been filled with
hydrogen and now you were coming in and
put
to present oxygen and to it maybe that's
not the smart way to do it so you just
mentioned briefly but we did Skylab and
flew to that for three times 28 days 56
and then 84 days and and we really
learned a bit about operating and of
course the Russians Soviets have been
doing Siyad stations and so after the
last landing there was a period of
daytime somewhat between the Soviet
Union and the United States the ABM
Treaty was signed and it was felt by
some people
I'm told that it was a an offer of
rewarding from us to the Soviets a
peaceful let's do a joint mission and
space you go up there and we'll come up
and rendezvous with you we'll build the
thing that will join the two of us
together and that became the joint
mission in space and looking back on it
it's a legacy that from 1975 up to the
present time has led to rather peaceful
sharing activities in space at the time
that the Soviet Union came apart and and
then other things happened and of course
I can't help but project into the future
now that that we could have a spacecraft
that could dock up with the Chinese and
and that could have that kind of a
long-term legacy of relations in space
that would be cordial peaceful and that
just might lead to
more acceptable peaceful relations here
on earth I know when you just been
speaking to Stephen Hawking because it
yesterday or the day before here and
then you had questions for him and I
noticed in one of his answers that he
said that he felt that Apollo was the
the most important thing that humanity
has done I suppose he meant as that the
first step out into the cosmos so of
course I suppose there's some modesty
involved here but I wanted to ask you
whether whether you feel that looking
back at the whole programme that from
through Mercury Gemini Apollo whether
that was perhaps the pinnacle of our
achievement so far well it certainly was
a bold step of progress when when we
made that commitment we hadn't even put
anyone in orbit yet so it it clearly was
a a big movement forward
the Russians have put Yuri Gagarin in
space were probably going to do and they
did many many more things but the
two-man spacecraft the Japanese
spacecraft is where we really began to
learn more things than the one man
mercury that couldn't even translate it
did rotate but not translate and you
have to translate with the Germany to be
able to make the rendezvous maneuver so
it was a very essential in between and
prepared us for being able to carry out
much more complicated things with Apollo
now having done that and seen what an
impact that had in our country and the
world I think that being able to do that
sort of a joint mission in space could
have long-term effects on it so the plan
I have starts out very briefly in
low-earth orbit and then does things at
the moon so that we can put things
together but we need all the nations to
come together we don't want to compete
with China that would just make it very
very messy right now they're they're
ahead of us by quite a bit because we've
made some decisions is we're not all
that productive but if we can do things
together in Earth orbit where we know a
good I'm at the moon where we know a
good thing about helping them Europe and
Japan Europe has a agreement with Russia
to work together at the moon and we the
United States would like to work with
the commercial people that could use the
war the ice the water and the fuel to be
able to aid and assist missions going
elsewhere to Mars so that's very
important so you see the return to the
moon is a development step a learning
step to learn to be so self-sufficient
on a body Bo well it enables us to help
the other nations and they jointly make
use of permanence we never had permit we
and then came back the last mission was
three days they had a rover but they
still landed and then came back so to
make activities on the moon you'd like
to leave land and stay there for a month
three months six months and and rotate
him keep somebody there all the time and
a permanent and that's the sort of thing
we'd certainly like to have at Mars so
the design should be the same and the
procedures of joining them together we
can learn at the moon so that we can
make sure we do it right because I'm
just actually about the the atmosphere
in NASA at that time because it strikes
me you know but I think everyone here is
probably a fan of space exploration but
that timescale in the fact that you
fight the first manned test flight of
Apollo is what is it October 68 December
68 you go around the moon July 69 you
land on the moon so less than a year
from first test flight well was the
atmosphere a test flying sort of rather
more military atmosphere we just we have
to do this and we will we will take
risks if necessary we will just get on
with it we'll do the engineering we'll
do it
what is that how different is that today
and the first question is what was the
atmosphere like at the time it was
competitive and because the at that time
the Russians in the sense were maybe a
little ahead of us we had the Apollo
fire loss three crewmembers in part of
one and so that slowed up our momentum
and then it it looked as though the
Russians had sent an unmanned spacecraft
and it was a small spacecraft that went
around the moon and then landed in aral
sea I think and they did that again
unmanned and landed in the normal
landing play
we're Russian lands and we felt it was
just a matter of time for them to put a
cosmonaut in there and go around the
moon
first so that's why we accelerated the
second mission of Apollo the Polaris
first was just in Earth orbit but the
second mission would have been the first
time anyone got on the big rocket and we
decided to send him to the moon and move
it very bold maneuver and it saved us
probably about six months and develop on
time
because then we could follow that with
testing the lunar module and earth orbit
and in lunar orbit and then we could
perhaps land so you just have an
atmosphere where everybody the engineers
the the astronauts everybody's focused
on whatever it takes to I remember I
remember talking to a who's Charlie Jude
can I ask him similar question he said
well you when you've got four hundred
thousand people and unlimited budget you
can do a lot it's that there's nothing
kind of atmosphere whatever it takes get
them headed in the right direction yeah
we're going to take some questions from
the audience in a moment but I just
wanted to ask you about Mars just
briefly because that that's your your
passion now isn't it just aiming to get
a mission to Mars well it's not like
it's a new thought
in 1969 July we landed and then they had
a space Task Group do some studies and
they looked at three levels of intensity
and the highest intensity they felt we
could get to Mars in the sometime in the
eighties nineteen eighties
and the slowest would still get to Mars
before the year 2000 that was very
optimistic stay but but there was that
focus on Mars as early as that and it
has been the ultimate objective for him
final five presidents now but there
hasn't been the steps leading to that
that make it a firm decision that's what
we're going to do so so the in the
eights is you would have used Saturn
fives or the bigger than Oh boom booster
and who knows what we would have used it
now
of course that was a great rocket
personally I think it it was better than
the rocket that was being worked on now
to be the rocket to take us to Mars but
there's been a lot of shifting around we
we felt we needed to do something that
was reusable and there was a study to
make quite an advanced reusable
two-stage that was cancelled and then we
rushed into the shuttle design and
perhaps in retrospect skipped a few
things because we had the crew and the
cargo in one big airplane so there's no
way to separate the crew except to take
the whole airplane with you and that was
decided not the thing to do after the
accident board so we by that time we
begun putting up a space station had
someplace to go and just while we're
talking about the future I just then we
note sit down you mentioned these the
two things that you're working on now so
you've got the Buzz Aldrin space
Institute
Florida Institute of Technology which is
really looking at the Mars missions but
with the with the cycler orbits yeah sir
perhaps you could just comment very
briefly on that because that's an
interesting ambitious planet president
bush's mission was called a vision for
space exploration and some of us decided
that a vision for space is more than
just exploration it's a number of things
but whatever it is we should unify space
vision and I enumerated the things and
nobody's improved on it but we have
exploration that we develop something no
sorry exploration and science is second
more important than we knowing the
science we develop that hopefully it can
become commercial and the last and most
important is security all of this must
lead to increasing the security of the
nation and that's why that gets more
resources so unified space vision is
what my plan was that would that tell
you very much
no it doesn't but we did a study of
rather complete at Purdue University and
then I decided I need to get a little
bit more concise this the feature of the
plan is getting Mars and the way to get
to Mars that is different from other
people's ways is to have a perpetual a
continuous cycling between Earth and
Mars and it may not go right back it
paid to you may have to cyclers and it
gets more economical that way and that
that has been
what we've been pursuing now but it's
cycling Orbitz so these are so I wanted
to call it cycling path ways to occupy
Mars not just visit and come back but to
keep Mars occupied you go and you stay
and other people come and then you may
come back so these are a stable orbit
you build a space station essentially
which is like a conveyor belt on several
space stations which are constantly
always in for free once you get them
going and you ride them backwards and
forwards transfer resources that's what
the idea is that unlike Apollo and
unlike this shuttle these are things
that have a bærum work for continued
exploration building one on top of the
other well you you first put a cycler
into the orbit you make sure but now
it's going to swing by the earth so as
they swing by you join up and it gets to
Mars and you get off now the only thing
that you need to take there is a lander
because the rest of the things have been
put together on the ground and the only
thing for the route of going is six
months worth of life support so if you
can take one lander maybe you can take
two or you can take three and and that
provides a system with redundancy if one
engine fails and you can discard that
and still get there with the other
systems other ways don't have that
because had one last question for you
open its the audience which is with a
commitment from the world as you said
everybody who scientific advance Nations
cooperating together when could you
begin to build that infrastructure if we
wanted to well that it would be
impossible to say if we got all the
nations together and said okay we're all
going to contribute to do this no one
nation could do it in a reasonable time
you'd have to be skipping and still you
would come up short or it would be very
costly in take a good bit of time and
besides the other nations Europe Russia
Japan China haven't gone to the moon yet
they would like to do that and then
maybe go to Mars I've always suspected
that if the Russians say oh we're going
to build a permanent base on the moon to
convince us that we should build a
permanent base and then they'll change
their mind in Elko to Mars but what we
we really don't want to do it that way
we want to help them not compete I mean
worst thing would be to compete with
China and it's not real peaceful in the
South China Sea right now but it wasn't
really that peaceful between the Soviet
Union and the United States back in 1975
so we could be doing some things in
orbit or at the moon and the Chinese
and chatting with them know that they
would like to have some of our
experience now maybe they're just
telling us that but I really think that
they would they know a lot more that we
knew back then but but I think it would
just be so unproductive for them to do
things their way and for us to try and
catch up the best way is to bring all
the nations together and then let China
advance and other nations will advance
but we can pool our resources and set up
a degree of permanent occupancy at the
move where people I go for six months
and then rotate cruise so there would
always be somebody there like the space
station doing different things like like
the space station
okay well let's let's have some
questions from the audience so so stick
your hand up and if you will and it's a
particularly valued questions from the
younger members of the audience actually
anyone does anyone here is there there's
one day yes gone nobody in the front row
yeah go ahead
so there's a vacuum on the moon this I
in space there's no air so when the Sun
comes on the surface it warms up the
surface and when the Sun is gone it the
heat leaves and the sun is shining for
14 days as it goes over because it takes
twenty-eight days for the moon to go
around the earth so when it's dark it
does get quite cold and a lot of the
spacecraft have to sort of be shut down
and maybe they won't wake up or after
being so cold and there's no atmosphere
the radiation from the Sun for a solar
flare
would be very difficult for people on
the moon as it would be for people
leaving the earth outside the magnetic
bouncing and heading somewhere else so
you need to apply some radiation
protection and that's still a little
debatable as to just how much to get rid
of all of it would be very very
expensive and very costly to put that
much weight up there so there's always a
compromise difficult to vacuum outside
the spacecraft in orbit is the same all
the way to Mars and all the way around
the moon it's it's a vacuum the Laird
Reid you got to take your oxygen along
with you so questions is that I find
quite difficult say oh there's one this
one right the front man that's great
okay such as Boeing well it certainly is
the the government spacecraft rate from
the beginning we didn't have any
comparison but they were not cheap and
if there hadn't been some company able
to put something together it would have
been rather expensive to do that
competing with the government but but
we've worked it so that the government
can help companies put together a
spacecraft and they'll have a contract
to then deliver people to the space
station
you start with delivering cargo first
and we're in the process of doing that
now with with two companies and it'll be
three pretty soon and then there are
some contracts already for SpaceX and
and also Boeing to take people up the
station we don't have the shuttle
anymore
and we don't have the commercial and we
don't have the government Orion now when
it was decided in beginning of for to
not fly the shuttle past 2010 we assumed
that seven years we could come up with
something but it's not there yet
and it probably won't be for until 2021
maybe so that means that if the
commercial companies can begin to take
people up then we won't have to use the
Russian Soyuz right now we're we're
paying twenty seventy million or more
for each astronaut to go up to a space
station that we've invested a hundred
billion dollars in that's not very smart
how did we get here well we need to look
back and see what it is and I've got a
think tank underway we're just looking
for a little funding but we're ready to
go to begin to look back at good things
not so good and also look to the future
so that's one project that I have
started but it's not underway the other
one is my cycling pathways Ford occupy
Mars and that year by year the
evolutionary steps at intermediate
objectives may be an asteroid may be
flyby Venus other people are doing
things at the moon were developing
refueling so that we can be able to put
things on the surface of Mars from the
moon of Mars and then eventually go and
land so it's a step by step so you don't
lose that momentum again you don't lose
AK disease as we did well it it still
starts off kind of slow but we're really
not ready to put a lot of money into it
I hope that that we can begin to build
that financial support to be able to
design efficient rockets and spacecraft
that that really are needed we take
another we may be let an older person
ask question well yeah I was going to
try and go further back you see then
when I write in the back there what was
someone at the back who's got their hand
up because it's not fair we've got that
we've got I think we were in that time a
bit but I was told we could overrun a
little bit because you know I don't got
anything urgent they want to do based
agree the breeze or the danger of being
operating in orbit Norris toughness now
it is a growing problem there's no doubt
about it and there are people working on
ways there's not a big incentive there's
not a prize for how much garbage you can
bring back maybe that would be a good
idea so it's just I can't be a good
thing to do it be a good thing to yeah
we have climate change not happening
but we have pressing things right now
and that's how do we get the other
nations together doing things that are
needed to have the confidence to then go
and put together a base on Mars and you
can't do that from the earth you can do
the slow-moving things close together
but it will take time now if you put
people at the moon of Mars it's much
better but it's costly to get people
there and and to have people at
the moon of Mars bringing bringing
pieces that are a mile apart that's
valuable time doing things that we could
have done from Earth if we take enough
time to do that and there are ways of
being able to space out the launches and
use launchers from all nations to be a
One Nation just couldn't do the things
that are necessary to build up a
location on Mars that you would be
confident of landing and and staying
there for several years some other
people could come and you could come
back there there are a lot of things
really should be done before the first
people go down and it is so much more
efficient without going into details to
Rovers on either side and five years
accomplished a certain amount that the
project manager said manager said what
they did in five years could have been
done in one week if we had human
intelligence in orbit so that we could
control things with a second time to
life instead of 15 minutes yeah you can
do a lot more science as well as this
project but it's nice if you have a pace
that lends itself to easy coming
together if they're just arbitrarily
that it's difficult say what we just
talked about miles in the future but we
start here in front of these images and
I just it is that occurred to me a
question I've never asked actually
because I don't I've met you flew on the
so the Atlas rocket wasn't it Gemini and
then and then the Saturn 5 on Apollo I
wondered what it was a their target the
Agena target flew on Atlas mercury caps
flew on atlas yeah a Gemini we flew on a
ICBM Titan Oh Titan heaven - yo mr. Josh
my question eh you got on top of an ICBM
and flew it into orbit and then you get
a number satirize did the same thing
what is it as a pilot how what are the
differences and how thrilling is it to
pilot that become a Saturn 5 is the most
powerful flying machine we've ever built
to this day right so what is it like to
pilot that thing did you feel your eye
not violent in your along for the ride
yeah that's such papers technically if
things did go wrong there's a way you
could do some steering nobody's ever
done it fortunately but but there is
that provision with the end controllers
that if the guidance for the engines
started to veer off that you could
possibly get it straightened away and
then separate yeah not bail out but
separate with parachute yeah compass
it's it's a very very different
experience than to flying a fast jet
fine an aircraft is it it does anything
prepare you for flying well the the
Germany spacecraft was really a pilots
spacecraft because you could renew ver
it you could go up down forward and you
could do the maneuvers to bring
spacecraft together and you could dock
as we did with our another rocket that
had a powerful engine and then it could
take you up to eight hundred miles that
we did that on on one mission we're
supposed to do it on Jimmy twelve but
something went wrong
we didn't do but that spacecraft really
was one that you could maneuver Apollo
was so programmed in its pathway that it
just wasn't the sort of thing that you
could move around everything was very
well orchestrated to be part of the
total total flight plan of getting there
yeah so so really the thing is that you
on the rocket you just sit there and
wait until you get into orbit but then
the then the flying start well you know
I get in before I go flying an airliner
I'm talked to the pilots and that I flew
around the world with some people knew
what they were doing and they set things
up with the buttons
it flies itself it's not being flown
except for landing in and take off so
we're getting very mechanical and and as
a result in some cases when the pilots
do take over to make a landing they're
not always as proficient as they should
be you can be too automated and if
something goes wrong when it's automated
you better know how to recover from it
me I take one last question but we busy
and so that I was reading Norman
Mailer's book a fire on the moon
recently which has this terrific
description of Apollo 11 taking off and
I'm so at that moment when the countdown
finishes and you take off are you busy
or ie what's going through your mind now
you're just thinking Christ this is this
isn't this is a hell of a ride or are
you really check this check this chat
listed well there's the thought in the
back of your mind you've gone through
all this preparation you're up there on
the top and they're beginning to
countdown a lot of times there's a hold
and then there's a scrub
and you got to come back down now you
got to go through all of that again one
or two days later you don't want to do
that so you're really hoping that
nothing goes wrong and when when the
engines light they're 300 feet below you
and and if you're out in the crowd it's
big loud noise shockwaves but you're up
here you don't hear that
I got a headset on and you're talking it
it increases a little bit no when the
three of us started talking about what
the liftoff was like we all three
concluded that the exact moment of
leaving the ground was not that
discernable except for the countdown but
there was not any force but we said to
each other we felt like we were being
guided with the guidance to most
dangerous part of that launch is going
sideways and crashing into the tower
because it's a big big boom and you may
not be able to get away from it in time
so when the rocket clears the tower
that's the point where the control from
the launch pad Kennedy Space Center the
control the spacecraft is switched over
to Mission Control in Houston once they
passed the tower clear and you relax
then
well but but we're still not feeling
that much it's smooth and gradually
pushed down and then about four minutes
we've reached about three and a half
four G's and we're pushed back we get it
smooth and what the engine cuts off we
sort of move ahead in the seat it is not
a traumatic we've seen pictures of the
shuttle when they take off to somebody
cameras going and they're bouncing
around like this it's the shockwaves
supposedly between the big solid Rockets
not knowing that much about I suspect
it's more than that
because they're four segments solid has
some instabilities near burnout and that
was a problem when we went to five
segments and that sort of terminated
that program of going to the moon in the
Vision for Space Exploration
in 2010 yeah it's still difficult to
build as Rocket Weaver is temporary
actually we supposed to feed you three
or they say one last question and then
we'll do got it and I know there's loads
of older feel is there any more younger
members of the audience area there's one
right over there let's do that that's
wrong you've been really wait
yeah that'd be great can you see him
there with the microphones
uh-huh can't see
there's no doubt that the technology has
has come a long ways when somebody tells
me that their iPhone has more computing
power than our computer did in the
spacecraft I did a little resentful now
I know we didn't have a lot of storage
but my answer to them is well so you
know I can take this and throw it open
here now can it take a star sighting and
know exactly what his position is and
can it command a maneuver of rockets can
it land now it's going to crash and
break
I can show a lot of pictures and a lot
of names and things it's all depends on
what you design something to do yes I've
seen the glass cockpits of airplanes and
and it is a marvel much much different
than when I flew in the Korean War and
ours were much better than the Russians
that the Koreans flew but there's still
a degree of automation and you have a
tendency to let the autopilot fly and
when you do that you're not getting the
feeling of the response of the craft so
I'm not legally flying but once I do go
with somebody and they let me fly the
airplane I'm not going to turn them
autopilot on I'm going to fly the thing
all I can to get the practice and we
will have we do drones flying around no
pilot him and four fighter pilots we
don't like to be out of a job
I love like the drone you don't have to
bring back your left to feed them I love
what you said that is it maybe it's a
great so many the spirit of the age when
you said even it exists today when you
said I'm not legally flying but when I
fly I don't want you to answer that why
I I do a lot of writing yeah you know
the rules now you can't be up in the
cockpit an airliner and but oh I
one more thing my father was the
contemporary of Jimmy Doolittle and in
world war ii he was the person that
called back both of them into world war
ii and Jimmy Doolittle trains right away
to take off from a carrier that would be
close to Japan and they would bomb Tokyo
and they did and they take off early so
a lot of them crashed in China or were
in prison and Russia but Jimmy tulo
became a real hero and and somebody that
I looked up to and when my father passed
away I spent a little bit more time
visiting with him and I just loved to
tell him because he was the first one to
take off on aircraft Gerrit and the
airplanes were behind him so he had the
shortest and I used to tell him
Jamia our rocket was taller than your
takeoff roll was 360 feet is all he had
to get airborne and his co-pilot is
still alive as a hundred years old yeah
yeah
and that's nice that was 30 years ago
wasn't it guys they've been having
reunions and that's where I want their
Apollo people in the German
people have reunions so we can build up
the public interest of what we were able
to do and what we may be able to do in
the future up to the 50th anniversary of
when we landed that should be a big deal
yeah yeah yeah that's a big deal for
some President to say we should land on
Mars yeah yeah yeah fitting tribute
wouldn't it but well I know many of you
perhaps all of you going to meet Buzz
and after the short break we're going to
have to get book signed it cetera
I just heard these t-shirts as well
there you can find these I think here
can you buy them me rather than because
because all the money's them for the
share Space Foundation which goes to the
one of the things that the giant
destination Mars map which is a huge map
making using schools and we were talking
before if there teachers here or you
want to tell your school you can buy
those things are you can apply for them
actually can't you on and they're funded
partly by these t-shirts I said it share
space dog yet but for now so we're going
to finish with a short video of the Tim
Peake launch talking about space as it
is today and we're going to retire for a
few minutes and then so you if you stay
seated and then buzz will come back with
the signing table etc and then you can
all come down and chat suppose you want
to find out more about what we're doing
Buzz Aldrin calm because I'm in order to
send this a message Twitter and the real
buzz yeah real buzz is there is there an
input an imposter there at Buzz Aldrin
is there an at Buzz Aldrin he's not the
real buzz buzz lightyear
so thank you okay thank you thank bugs
again